the night in the journal hello youtubers
so today my eye with a question from
NASA naka and mystogan 3484 about how
unemployment rates are rising in the
world and often because technology is
replacing labor the question is how do
we solve the unemployment crisis and
improve the standards of living when
there's rapid technology is that may be
impairing jobs so my name is David you
bitch I'm the CEO and Founder opendns
and are getting my shot at answering the
question so first something technologies
in a blur of progress right so when we
have technology can enable communication
but it also enables education so not
only in the enterprise in the business
world where we use technology to making
takata faster and happen and safer ways
and lower costs we can also use
technology to enable education so people
worldwide can use technology to enhance
learning and to bring phenomenal
teachers in material that might not be
accessible to them and bring it to their
front door so whether it's through the
eastern things like the iPad for the no
knowledge book the idea of using
technology to spread information to
educate people and part of the world
where they might not otherwise have the
ability to recently reached those
resources really I think a little more
technology as a way to just sort of
sponsor and even act as a catalyst wrong
to the neurochip one of the greatest
ways to create jobs into boosted
Romanian to solve the economic crisis is
through entrepreneurship so I really
believe that technology even with
short-term may appear to be replacing
some jobs it will herald a new era in
error that we've seen over the last
hundred years but even continuing into
the next hundred years of using
technology to create new businesses
educate people and remote remote
villages remote places in the world give
them access to information access to
more communication will ultimately
result in boosting the economy
you know the internet except you take is
one small example the internet has been
one of the twelve hundred trillion
dollars worth of wealth and values in
the world and that's only in the last 20
years so if you think about what I'll
hop in the 800 years thanks to
technology I you know I imagine there
will be many times thanks